انها الثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياضه نصهايب شراير وهذه اخبار
الساعه
بين ماكرون اتفاق على ايران واوكرانيا
وخلاف على الطاقه ودعم اقتصاد اوروبا
وفي اخبار المونديال المغرب المتصدر يبلغ
دور السته عشر بكاس العالم لاول مره بعد
36 عاما
رغم المطالب الدوليه لايران باحترام حقوق
الانسان رئيسي يدعو مجددا لقمع محتجي
كردستان
موجه برد شديده تشهدها مخيمات النازحين
بالمغرب
ومخاوفوا من تسجيل وفيات الكاميرا العربيه
تنقل الصوره
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه اذا نبداوها
بالاخبار العاجله التي وردت قبل قليل
اخبار نقلا عن وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه
التي فرضت اذا عقوبه اضافيه مرتبطه بحزب
الله اللبناني كما فرضت عقوبات على ثلاثه
افراد على صله بكوريا الشمالي
[موسيقى]
في بيان المشتركين للرئيس الامريكي جوبا
ايدين والفرنسيه اكد الرئيسان على حرص
البلدين على عدم تطوير ايران او حيازه
سلاح النووي
وماكرون في البيان المشترك الشهداء بشجاعه
المحتاجين في ايران مؤكدين دعمهما لهم وشر
البيان الى حرص الولايات المتحده وفرنسا
على بناء منظومه دفاعيه الاوروبيه قويه
الى جانب دعم اوكرانيا في فصل الشتاء سواء
بتعزيز انظمه الدفاع الجوي او توريد معدات
الاصلاح المحطات الطاقه واكد بايضا اذا
نتهما للتجارب الصاروخيه التي اجرتها
كوريا الشماليه خلال هذا العام
تاريخ طويل من العلاقات الامريكيه
الفرنسيه احتفل بها الرئيسان الامريكي
جوبتا ونظيره الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون
حفاوه واضحه كانت في الاستقبال لكن تمت
خلافات تدور في الخفاء اعترف بها ماكرون
مصرحا ان هناك خلافات عده مع واشنطن لكنه
سيتم بحث كيفيه تجاوزها بلفات عديده موضع
خلاف بين الطرفين تجاوزت حدود فرنسا لتشمل
اوروبا بدايه
المقدمات بموجب القانون الامريكي لخفض
التضخم الى الحرب في اوكرانيا ووصولا الى
ازمه الطاقه وسيتطرق الرئيس سامي الى
خلافات اخرى خلال هذه الزياره فقد اسفه
ماكرون الاربعاء بلهجه حازمه لقرارات
اقتصاديه اتخذها نظيره الامريكي اعتبرها
شديده العدائيه حياه الشركات الاوروبيه
وبالعوده الى العلاقات الامريكيه الفرنسيه
في عهد نذكره انها لم تبدا بشكل جيد خصوصا
بعد اعلان بيضا عن تحالف عسكري ضخم جديد
مع بري واستراليا وهو ما عرف بتحالف اوكس
ما ادى الى الغاء عقد هائل اتبعوا بموجبه
فرنسا غواصات الى كمبيرا ربما اقرب ايضا
بخطئه بالتعامل مع فراس انا ذاك وترجم هذا
على شكل حفاوه بالاستقبال يقول محلل
اذا هو مشاهدينا نعود ونذكر بالاخبار
العاجله والعقوبات اذا التي فرضتها
الخزانه الامريكيه على حزب الله اللبناني
وكذلك همم عقوبات اضافيه على كوريا
الشماليه
كله كله
[موسيقى]
في الوقت الحالي تتم مناقشه اسعار الطاقه
على المستوى العالمي وليس على مستوى رئيسي
دولتين لاعتقد ان لقائهما سيحدث فرقا
بالاضافه الى ذلك بالنسبه للنفط فهو محصور
بيد منظمه اوبك ونحن للاسف نعاني من ذلك
مع الاصدقاء الامريكيين وخاصه فيما يتعلق
بالامور الحاليه التي لا يعتقد انها تتعلق
فقط بالطاقه التي لن تكون موضوعا رئيسا
بلد المواضيع السياسيه
الجديده التي يتم بناءها حاليا
اذا كان يريد التحدث عن ارسال الم من
الاسلحه الى اوكرانيا فهذا جيد اوديك خير
اعتقد انه من الجيد جدا ان يكون لرئيس
فرنسا علاقات جيده مع رئيس الولايات
المتحده واعتقد ان لدينا رئيسنا يتمتع
بمهاره دوليه جيده وسيجد الحلول لتحقيق
التوازن بين الطرفين
للمزيد معنا من واشنطن دكتور وليد فارس
الخبير في السياسه الخليجيه الامريكيه
دكتور وليد اهلا بك معنا هل هذه الحفاوه
الكبيره والود كذلك الذي ظهر بين الرئيسين
بيضا وماكرون يعني انهما قادران على تجاوز
الخلافات بين امريكا وفرنسا
مصنع كثير من الكلام اليوم في الصحافه
والاعلام عن خلافات انا اضعها في اطار اخر
اعتقد انه العلاقه بين مكرون وبيضن بين
المجموعتين
السياسيتين هي علاقه جيده واستراتيجيه
ولكن هنالك طرق مختلفه تعمل فرنسا على
اتخاذها تختلف عن اداره ايضا لانه اداره
بيض المرتبطه بامور كثيره اولا اداره بيض
المرتبطه بدعم تقريبا ده متناهي في هذه
المرحله دي اوكرانيا ضد روسيا فرنسا
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه اكبر منها
في فرنسا ماكرون في فرنسا لا يعرضه احد
بموضوع عمليه
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه المجلس
النيابي سوف يعرضه اذا هنالك
على شكل العام موحد ولكن النهج والطريقه
مختلفه بين الدوله
ان كان بمساله الغواصات اييه سابقا وان
كان مساله الان قانون خفض التضخم الذي قال
ماكرون قالها بشكل واضح همم نواب امريكيين
قال لهم انه ممكن ان يحل مشكله التضخم في
امريكا ولكنه يزيد يزيد من المشكلات
الفرنسيه هل هذا برايك يعني هو عباره عن
ضغط من اجل التوصل الى تسويات في الملفين
اللذين ذكرتهما يعني همم الحرب في
اوكرانيا والنووي الايراني
اولا الرئيس ماكرون يحتاج ان يقول الراي
العام الامريكي ان هو ليس يتبع اميريكا
هدف تقليد فرنسي سياسي
على الفارق بين ماكرون وترامب وذلك وادي
العميق بين الاثنين
يعني الامور المشتركه بالطبع هنالك
المصلحه القوميه الفرنسيه
او العلاقات الثنائيه الامريكيه الفرنسيه
الملفان الاساسيان الان هم الاتفاق اتفاق
النووي الايراني لانه في ارباحيين وعمليه
انهاء كيفيه انهاء ملف الحرب في اوكراني
يعني
نعم طيب ايه بالنسبه بدت مساله اخرى لافته
دكتور وليد رئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل عندما
تحدث الى الجاليه الفرنسيه استخدم مصطلح
يعني يبدو لافتا قال انه هذه الخيارات
التي تتخذها امريكا الان تشردم الغرب
مشددا على انه هذه الخيارات لا يمكن ان
تنجح الا اذا كان هناك تنسيق بيننا اذا
اتخذنا القرارات معا اذا تناغمنا مجددا
كما قال مكروه حرفيا هل يمكن للغرب ان
يتناغم مجددا وكيف دكتور وليد
الغرب الذي هو متفق على الملفات الاساسيه
بامكانه طبعا ان يتناغم كما كان الوضع في
السنتين الماضيهتين وفي ثمان سنوات لحكم
او لرئاسه اوباما الذي اذن الان وهو يهدد
هذا التناغم هو الانقسام هنا في واشنطن
وليس في باريس يعني بعد شهر يناير سيكون
هنالك كونغو الجديد هذا الكونغرس سوف
يعارض بيضا بالكبيره والصغيره وكان ماكرون
يقول لبيضن انا هنا لمساعدتك ولكن انتم
ايضا ساعدوني نعرف ان عندكم معارضه شرسه
سوف تاتي بعد بعد قليل بعد بدعه اسابيع
عمليا وبالتالي علينا ان نتعاضد وان نتكلم
قراءه قراءه
المعادله حاليا شكرا جزيلا لك دكتور وليد
فارس الخبير في السياسه الخارجيه
الامريكيه كنت معنا منه
هذا واكد رئيس الفرنسيه انه سيجري محادثات
خلال الايام المقبله مع نظيره
في تصريحات لشبكه اي بي سي الامريكيه ان
الحرب في اوكرانيا معقده وتتطلب العمل
للوصول الى سلام عادل ومستدام لا يفرض على
الاوكرانيين او يرفضه احد الطرفين على
المدى المتوسط او البعيد واكد ماكرون
ارتكب خطا لكن ليس من الممكن العوده الى
المفاوضات
[موسيقى]
في خطوه ربما تبدو غريبه ان بعض الشيء
كياف تخصص خطا ساخنا لاتصال الجنود الروس
الراغبين في الاستسلام الحكومه الاوكرانيه
تؤكدت ان خطه الخط الساخن الذي وضعته
للجنود الروسي للاستسلام يصله ما يقرب من
100 استفسار يوميا المشروع الذي اطلق عليه
اسم اريد ان اعيش اطلقته كيف في سبتمبر
الماضي اذ يمكن للقوات الروسيه من خلال
الاتصال بخط ساخن او ادخال التفاصيل عبر
التطبيقات التراسل ترتيب افضل طريقه لعيد
القوات الاوكرانيه مسؤولون في قياس قالوا
ان لديهم بيانات اكثر من ثلاثه الاف 1500
شخص وعائلاتهم من افراد القوه الروسيه
وكانت هناك زياده واضحه منذ ان حشد الرئيس
مئات الالاف من الرجال الروس وبعد تحرير
مدينه خيرسون كذلك
شبكه بي بي سي الاخباريه ذهبت اكثر في
تفاصيل هذا الموضوع اذ نشرت معلومات هنا
في تقرير لها عن لقاء مع احدى الموظفات
اللواتي يتحدثن الى الجنود الروسي يوميا
موظفه المكالمات قالت فان اوقات المساء
تكون اكثر ازدحاما عندما يكون لدى القوات
المزيد من الوقت وقت الفراغ ويمكن تسلل
الجنود واجراء المكالمات مشيره الى ان بعض
الجنود الروسي يتواصلون بهم لاستفزازهم
رغم انها لا تعتقد انهم جميعا يصدقون
ادعاءات الكريملين
[موسيقى]
قال دبلوماسيون في الاتحاد الاوروبي انها
حكومات الدول الاعضاء اتفقت مبدايا اليوم
على حد الاقصى لاسعار النفط الروسيه
المنقول بحرا قدره 60 برميل 60 دولارا
للبرميل مع اليه تعديل لابقاء سقف السعد
اقل ب 5% من سعر السوق فقال الدبلوماسيه
ان بولندا هي التي ضغطت من اجل خفض الحد
الاقصى للاسعار قدر الامكان ولكن يحتاج
الاتفاق بعد ذلك لموافقه مكتوبه من جميع
حكم الدول الاتحاد الاوروبيه حتى يوم
الجمعه في ما قالت الخارجيه روسيه بان
موسكو لن تزود اي دوله توافق على وضعي
سقفا لسعر نفتحها
[موسيقى]
اذا الى الخبر المفرح عربيا في المونديال
اذا تاهل المنتخب المغربي متصدر مجموعته
السادسه كاس العالم بقطر بعد فوزه على
المنتخب الكندي بهدفين مقابل هدفين واحد
ووصل رصيد المنتخب المغربي الى سبع نقاط
متفوقا على كرواتيا التي جمعت خمسه نقاط
وبلجيكا باربع نقاط بينما جاء المنتخب
الكندي في المركز الاخير بثلاثه
وينتظر المنتخب المغربي والصيف المجموعه
الخامسه في دور ال16
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مغربي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اذا فرحه كبيره مبروك لاسود الاطلس اا
معانا مباشره من الرباط مراسل العربيه
عادل الزبيري ومن الدوحه منفذ العربيه
ليست بازاري ااا طبعا فرحه عارمه في
المشهدين مع الجماهير المغربيه الفرحه
كثيرا بهذا الانجاز التاريخي السعودي لدور
16 لاول مره منذ 36 عاما عادل ابداء معك
في العاصمه المغربيه وليد الرجراجي مدرب
بالمغرب نفسه قال انه اسعد شخص في العالم
اليوم كيف هي الجماهير
[تصفيق]
الصوره هنا في شارع محمد الخامس في
العاصمه المغربيه الرباط الجماهير تحاصرنا
فرحا وحبا كل الجماهير المغربيه من النساء
من الرجال
[تصفيق]
هنا فريحه
الفرحه يعني لا تسال خاربه في ثاني وصول
الى ربع النهائي همم
تعليقك على فوز المنتخب المغربي والتاهل
الدور الثاني
مبروك مبروك
[موسيقى]
هذه الاجواء
لهذه المشجعه لماذا خرجت الى الشارع
على العرب لعموما وعلى المغرب خاصه انها
فرحه كبيره نس
اعدونا المنتخب
الكل يريد ان يعبر السعاده
ليس فقط لدى الشعب المغربي وشجيع المغربي
كل الشعوب العربيه فرح بهذا الانجاز
العربي اذا والاهازيج تضغط على اي صوت
الان كذلك المشهد يبدو من خلفك ليث بذل
الكلمه التي تفضل
[تصفيق]
ولكن
الجماهير مبروك علينا
يعني
الدوره المقبل
يا شباب
نعم نعم الشباب
واقف ولكن
في وسط الدوحه الجميع يحتفل من وين حضرتك
قريبه من الدار البيضاء فانا اخر شيء
كانسلم على ال 16 واحنا جئناش همم
بلاسكم باش نشجعوا المنتخب المغربي وانتم
عملوا ايجاد تاريخي وان شاء الله علاش لا
كاس العالم للعربي
نعم هذه للدفات يعني كثير شباب عندهم حتى
شاب فلسطيني اذا نشجع احد بيحكي كلمه
للمغرب تفضل طيب بدايه مبروك للوطن العربي
جميعه على هذا الفوز العظيم فوز المغرب
الف مبروك للوطن العربي واحنا بنقول احنا
بنقول هارد لك هارد لك الفرق العربيه اللي
خسرت ام ماء ما خسرت محالفها الحظ الفرق
العربيه قدمت والسعوديه قدمت والف مبروك
للمغرب للوطن العربي كله والمغرب راح توصل
للنهايه باذن الله كلمه جميله جدا تحياتنا
لكل الجماهير الفلسطينيه كذلك والعربيه
هذه اقوى رساله لفرحه هي فرحه عربيه اذا
والانجاز عربي بامتياز همم كل الشعوب
العربيه هي وراء الاسود الاطلس الان مع كل
الثمانيات اذن بالوصول الى همم الربع
النهائي والنصف النهائي ولما النهائي كما
ذكرت لايف شكرا جزيلا لك اذا همم من
الدوحه وعادل شكرا من الرباط
[موسيقى]
وعلى ذكر المنتخبات العربيه في كاس العالم
على الرغم من ان المنتخب السعودي ودعا كاس
العالم امس الى ان الاداء القوي وخصوصا
الفوز على الارجنتين في اولى مبارياته ادى
الى تصدر السعوديه التراند العالميه على
شبكات التواصل الاجتماعيه بكل اللغات فما
هي القيمه التسويقيه لهذا الانتشار
الاعلاميه وكيف تستفيد منه المملكه في
جهودها للترويج لنفسها كوجه سياحيه دوليه
الاجابه في التقرير
لحظه انتهاء مباراه السعوديه والارجنتين
في كاس العالم كان اسم المملكه يتصدر
الترند العالمي على مختلف شبكات التواصل
الاجتماعي وبكل لغات العالم لا حديث
لمليارات من البشر الا هذه البلاد التي
هزمت الاسطوره ليونيل ميسي ورفاقه يحدث
ذلك في ما تبذل المملكه جهودا على مستويات
عده للترويج لنفسها كوجهه عالميه سياحه
البلاد عالميا قيمه ماديه يقدرها بعد
خبراء التسويق ب 30 مليار ريال
فمن اين اتى هذا الرقم
انا في التسويق عند شيء نسميه الاعلان او
الاعلام المدفوع هذا واضح جدا حسبته ولكن
الاهم والاكثر كلفه وهو الاعلام المكتسب
او الارنب ميديا بمعنى اخر لو اردنا ان
نحدث نفس الاثر كم لازم ندفع الاحداث هذا
الاثر ال 30 مليار تعتبر حتى توقع متحفظ
الوصول لهذه النتيجه هو الاثر العظم اللي
ظهر في صوره المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الحدث يتخطى رياضه كره القدم صناعه تجتذب
استثمارات ب 100 مليارات الدولارات
وقوامها الاساسيه الاعلان والترويش
والسعوديه بدات منذ سنوات مسيره الترويج
نفسها كوجهه سياحيه عالميه
فكيف تستفيد من التفات العالم الاسلامي
الاستفاده من هذه الفرص في الترويج بشكل
اكبر للسياحه السعوديه لاحظنا ارتفاع في
البحث عن كلمه المملكه العربيه السعوديه
او السعوديه من خلال محركات البحث من خلال
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ونطم ايضا
للاستفاده بهذه الفرصه اليوم مقيمين مجلس
ديوان التعاون الخليجي اللي موجودين في
قطر وباقي الدول ايضا حامل لبطاقه هي ممكن
الدخول للمملكه العربيه السعوديه تاشيره
سياحيه مجانيه خلال فتره المونديال هذه
كلها بتكون حافز وداعم لتطوير القطاع خلال
هذه الفتره معرفه اكبر عن السعوديه
وتعطيهم فرصه لزياره السعوديه مره واثنين
وثلاثه
النهوض الذي تشهده السعوديه منذ اطلاق
رؤيه 20 30 لا يتوقف عند القطاعات
الاقتصاديه بل يبني على النهوض بالموسيقى
والثقافه والرياضه التي تربط الشعوب
وسياحه هي القطاع الذي يدمج بينها جميعا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
اذا رفيع يقر بمقتل 13 الف جندي اوكراني
في الحرب مع روسيا لا يمكن تخيل كاس
العالم او اي مباراه كره قدم حول العالم
من دون بطاقات حمر فهذه البطاقات التي
يوجهها الحكام للاعبين المخالفين بهدف
فرديه النظام على اللعبه ماتت تستخدم في
الاحاديث بين الناس عند الكلام عن الطرد
والانذار صاحب فكره البطاقه الصفراء
والحمراء
رجل انجليزي توفي في عام 2001 بعد سلسله
من المساهمات في عالم كره القدم
استوحى فكره البطاقات من اشارات المرور في
الشارع
وترجمها على هيئه الاصفر للتهدئه والاحمر
للتوقف وذلك للتغلب على اي حواجز لغويه
وظهرت البطاقات الصفراء والحمراء في كاس
العالم عام 1970 في المكسيك ومن دون ذلك
الحين اصبحت جزءا لا يتجزا من اللعبه
لا انه قبل ذلك كان يحصل الطرد والانذار
بطريقه شفهيه
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه رغم المطالب
الدوليه لايران باحترامي حقوق الانسان
رئيسي يدعو مجددا لقمع محتجعي كردستان
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد في شمال سوريا لم تتوقف
الضربات التركيه منذ اكثر من اسبوع وقوافل
متتاليه للتحالف الدولي تدخل المنطقه في
رساله للتاكيد على الوجود الامريكي
حقوق الانسان اكد ان عده قوافل الدولي ضد
داعش دخلت شمال شرق سوريا خلال 48
بحسب المرصد القوافل القادمه من معبر
الوليد الحدودي مع اقليم كردستان العراق
وتوجهات الى قواعد التحالف المنتشره في
محافظه الحسكه واحسن نشطاء المرصد السوري
اكثر من 200 شاحنه تحمل على متنها مدافع
واسلحه الرشاشه ثقيله ومعدات عسكريه
مغلقه او مغلقه بالاضافه الى صهاريج
ومن سوريا الى انقره فقد اكد مجلس الامن
القومي التركيه ان انقره لن تسمح بوجود اي
نشاط وصفته بالارهابي على حدودها اشار
المجلس في بيان الله عقب اجتماعه برئاسه
اردوغان الى ان تركيا ستتخذ كل ما يلزم من
اجراءات لتحقيق ذلك هو بشكل حاسب اكد
المجلس وانه بحث خلال الاجتماع التدابير
الاضافيه الممكنه بشان العمليات المستمره
داخل البلاد وخارجها
[موسيقى]
الى ايران الان وسط الاحتجاجات المستمره
صعدت ايران من جهودها لقتل واختطاف
النشطاء والصفيين المعارضين وقمع
المحتاجين صحيفه شرق الاصلاحيه افادت بان
النظام الايراني قام باعتقال مراسله
المناصله الصحفيه ستران فروخه وصادروا
هاتفها المحمول وهاتف افراد عائلتها وجهاز
الكمبيوتر الخاص بها وكانت صحيفه استاذنا
ذكي اليوميه الاصلاحيه قد اوردر نهايه
اكتوبر الفائت انا اكثر من 20 صحفيا ما
زالوا قيد الاحتجاج خصوصا في ايران اما
مجله جيهان صنعت الاقتصاديه فاغلقت
ابوابها الاسبوع الماضي بعد توجيهها
اتهاما الى قوات الامن بحسب ما اعلن
القضاء الايراني لجنه حمايه الصحفيين
الدوليه نشرت في وقت سابقا اسماء الصحفيين
والنشاطاء الذين اعتقلهم النظام الايراني
وعلى راس القائمه جاء اسمه صحفيهتين يلدا
ميري مصوره صحفيه ونيلوفر حميدي الم ده
الصحفيه لصحيفه شرق شبه الاصلاحيه وهما
اول من تكلم عن اسباب وفاتي مهسا امير
تالي قائمه طويله من ابرز الصحفيين
والنشطاء الذين اعتقدرون
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الى الاراضي الفلسطينيه الان رفع الجيش
الاسرائيلي درجه التاهب في الضفه الغربيه
وفي المنطقه الجنوبيه على حدود قطاع غزه
تحسبا لرد من حركه الجهاد على عمليه قتل
واحد من ابرز قياداتها في مخيم جنين شمالي
الضفه في عمليه اقتحام المباغته للمخيم
اسفلت عن مقتل فلسطينيين واصابه اخرين
واعتقالي عدد من المطربين تقول اسرائيل
انهم كانوا في صدده سياره مفخخه
لاستخدامها ضد المستوطن
مع جروح الليل قوه اسرائيليه خاصه تحاصر
مبنا سكني على اطراف مخيم جنين سرعان ما
تحول الحصار الى اشتباكات المسلحه عنيفه
[تصفيق]
قتلت القوه المداهمه نعيم الزبيدي ومحمد
السعدي احد قاده كتيبه جنين ومقاتلا في
سرايا القدس التابعه لحركه الجهاد
اضرب الوحدات العام في جنين مع تشييع
جثمان الشابين وسط مخاوف اسرائيليه من رد
قد يكون من الجنوب اذ سبقوا ان ردت حركه
الجهاد باطلاق الصواريخ من غزه ردا على
عمليات اغتيال في الضفه
والاستفراد بالدم الفلسطيني
[موسيقى]
الجيش الاسرائيلي رفع درجه التاهب في
الضفه الغربيه وفي الجنوب والذي تلونت
سماؤه بخطوط بيضاء نتاجا تجارب صاروخيه
تجريها الفصائل في غزه وفي الضفه الغربيه
التي قتل فيها الجيش الاسرائيلي سبعه
فلسطينيين في اليومين الماضيين انتشار
وتجديد على الحواجز خشيه عمليات رد فيما
تواصل السلطه الفلسطينيه شكواها بعدم وجود
شريك اسرائيلي يؤمن بالسلام ويعمل مع
الجهات الرسميه لنزع فتيل للانفجار
في اسرائيل يؤمن بحل الدولتين على اساس
الشرعيه الدوليه
والاتفاقات الموقعه ونبذ العنف والارهاب
بذريعه الانذارات الساخنه والقنابل
الموقوته والتخطيط لعمليات تواصل اسرائيل
تصعيدها في الضفه الغربيه موقعه مزيدا من
الضحايا ومع كل جنا يشيعها الفلسطينيون
تعلو الاصوات المطالبه بالانتقام لتتحول
لعمليات دهس وطعن وقد تتطور لما تخشاه
اسرائيل من عمليات تفجير وسيارات مفخخه
كما حدث مؤخرا في مدينه القدس عبد الحفيظ
جعوان العربيه الاراضي الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه بركان مولانا
وفي جزيره هاواي يستيقظ من سباته ويواصل
ثور الاخر
[موسيقى]
مرحبا بكم من جديد الى اليمن حيث تزداد
معاناه النازحين في الخيام المهتدئه وسط
التجمعات النزوح بمحافظه
البرد كاميرا العربيه تنقل معاناه
النازحين تويتر
لا يختلف الحال كثيرا عن بقيه تجمعات
النزول
البردي تزداد المخاوف من تسجيل حالات
وفيات جديده من الاطفال وكبار السن في
خيام مهترئه ممزقتها الرياح
يعانون كثيرا من شده البرد النازحون ما
فيه الا عيدان وترابيل يصلحونها نريد نريد
حلول جذريه النازحين في هذا المخيم يوجد
لنا همم مخيمات حلوه جدا كناتير حلول
جذريه بحيث نازح همم يحصل ماوى ضمه اولاده
تحاول النسوه بعد ان فقدنا ازواجهن في
الحرب جمعه اغصان الاشجار ثم تغطيتها
بالترابيل والاقمشه في محاوله لتوفير مسكن
امن لابنائهن يقيهم موجه البرد القارس
فيما ام ياسر التي حصلت على احدى الخيام
تجهز بيديها ماده الاسمنت لتسد الفجوات
التي تتسلل منها الرياح البارده وهكذا
الحال من التجهيزات البسيطه للنازحين في
ظل غياب المسكن الملائم لطبيعه المنطقه
وظروف النزوح
قرصها معرش الجهال هكذا واحد جنب واحد جنب
واحد علشان يدخله وسطه كل يوم نسوي بطانيه
وتكمل بطانيه وتقطع من الشمس من الرياح
ونرجع ثاني وعلى هذا طرد عسل
شبكه
ونشتري نسدد على نفوسنا هكذا
دافيه
عرضتها المنظمات الاغاثيه واقرتها كتله
الماوى وواحده النازحين في مارب العام
الماضي لكنها لم تصل للنازحين الى اليوم
لذا يحاولون تامين مساكنه تقيهم واطفالهم
موجه البرد القادمه من اعواد الاشجار
محمود الحميدي لقناه العربيه مارب
[موسيقى]
اعلان مقتل ثاني زعيم داعش خلال اقل من
عام واحد ضربه موجعه تلقاها تنظيم بعد
مقتل زعيمه ابو الحسن الهاشمي القرشي في
اكتوبر الماضي ضربه اثار التساؤلات عده
حياه هيكله التنظيم والمزيد من الاجابات
اعلان مقتل ثاني زعيم لتنظيم داعش خلال
عام واحد ضربه اخرى موجعه تلقاها التنظيم
على اثر اعلان مقتل زعيمه ابو الحسن
الهاشمي القرشي وذلك بعد محاصرته من قبل
مقاتلين محليين في بلده جاسم بسوريا
منتصفه اكتوبر الماضي
مقتل ابو الحسن الهاشمي اثار تساؤلات عده
حول تنظيم داعش وما هو السيناريو المنتظر
له اهي ضربه معنويه ام تنظيميه ستحمل
تداعيات على هيكله التنظيم نفسه
خبراء ذكروا ان مقتل القيادات لن يؤثر على
التنظيم لا على المستوى الاستراتيجي او
على المستوى التمدد والانتشار لتنظيم داعش
الذي يرسم مسارات مستقبليه فيما وصفه
اخرون انه لن يمثل اي نهايه للتنظيم من
حيث الايديولوجيا او التخطيط
والاستراتيجيه القائمه له
لكن سرعه الاعلان عن تعيين ابو الحسين
الحسيني خالفا للقرش تعكس محاوله التنظيم
قطع الطريق على اي انشقاق وخلافات ويحمل
ايضا تعيين ابو الحسين القرشي زعما
للتنظيم رساله مهمه بالنظر الى ما عرف عنه
وصفا بانه متطرف عنيد وهو من الدائره
المقربه لابو الحسن القرشي
الا انه ومع كل تصفيه او اغتيال لزعماء
الصف الاول في التنظيم تبرز تساؤلات عن
السيناريوهات المستقبليه وتشير الخريطه
الامنيه والتنظيميه ان المسرح الاكثر
ترجيحا لعمليات داعش ستكون الصحراء
الافريقيه نظرا الى عوامل محليه اساسيه
اضافه الى عوامل اخرى اقليميه
الولايات المتحده يوصل لبركان ماونال
وتورانا البركان الذي يوجد في جزيره هاواي
يعد اكبر بركان للنشر في العالم وبدات
ثورانه منذ الاحد الماضي الى ان وصلت تدفق
حمامه مؤخرا الى اسفل الجبل الذي يعتلي
قمته في الجزيره
[موسيقى]
ومن البراكين الى الفيضانات حيث ظهرت
لقطات جويه من ولايه سانتا كاترينا جنوب
البرازيل لحظه انقاذ العائلات التي حصلت
بسبب الفيضانات التي غرقت مساحات من
المدينه تحت المياه الموحده فيما تم اجلاء
اكثر من 880 شخصا حتى الان
[موسيقى]
اذا مشاهدينا تنتهي اخبار الساعه الان
طبعا يوم كروي في المونديال كان حافلا
ومهم جدا طبعا فوز المغرب في المنتخب
العربي الوحيد الى الدور المقبل والمانيا
التي لم تنتهي المباراه
[موسيقى]